uh sir can we help you Lenny Lenny what
are you doing greetings ladies and
gentlemen looked at a person at your
left now look at me now look to the
person on your right now back at me
sadly they are not me however at their
to become a Carnegie Mellon loyal Scott
they could become like me
look at your hand now look at mine
what's in it loyal Scott chapstick it
tastes of delicious butterscotch and
it'll make your lips buttery smooth look
around you where are we you're at greek
sing 2011 just by being here you are one
step closer to becoming a loyal Scott
like me I'm very proud of you all the
next receps are very easy and I'm sure
you've already accomplished them now
you're only one step away from achieving
the machismo that is me what's in my
pocket five dollars that is all you need
to donate to your favorite organization
in order to complete your daunting task
well ladies and gentlemen I've done all
I can do here unparallel pride in your
school and bulging biceps await it's up
to you to take the challenge i'm on a
horse